[Music]
in 2004 I set up an organization called
the London feminist Network and we
revived the women's reclaim the night
march they hadn't been won in London for
some time and they started in Britain in
the 1970s oh I'm going to go on and talk
about that history a bit more and we
revived the March and it started off
with 50 women in 2004 and it became
quite quite big over the years and went
on to we have you know over 2000 on
several occasions and those marches are
now held all across the UK as well so
I've been involved in feminist activism
for a long long time and also in policy
work around domestic violence prevention
and domestic violence prevention
education for local education
authorities worked with Women's Aid and
various other things and for my Phyllis
Phyllis book I interviewed and surveyed
over 100 fun feminist activists across
the UK some from the 1960s and 70s and
some activists who've only been involved
in the current resurgence so they were
all different generations of activists
they had a lot of different political
identifications the most popular that
people chose to label themselves when
they picked a label was socialist
feminist and socialist and feminist so
some people split them into two rather
than put them together and quite a lot
of radical feminists responded to my
survey I need to use as well which you
know methodologically is probably
because I know you know aligning myself
with that school of feminism's it
started in 1977 it's a women's march
against rape and all forms of male
violence against women and against
sexual harassment in the public sphere
it's not to be confused with the much
more recent [ __ ] walk which started in
Canada and the US that's a much more
recent invention reclaimed annoy is
about some of the same things but it
chooses to keep its clothes on which is
I think probably the most
or thing that women can do in this
culture is keep their clothes on and
open their mouths and say stuff instead
so [ __ ] walk of course got a lot of
media attention for men and women
wearing what would be considered you
know revealing or provocative clothing
whatever you want to call it I don't
even use that term Spartan I have lots
of issues with that much anyway perhaps
we can talk about some of that stuff
later so it began then well it began in
Leeds actually in the 1970s but there
was a lot of stuff leading up to it
really
so 71 Susan Brown Miller and the New
York radical feminists they held what is
the first documented speak out now speak
outs being quite popular and they're
much more well-known now this is where
survivors of broken male violence are
given a safe space to stand up and talk
about what what happened to them it was
seen at the time it's still seen now as
very taboo breaking it's seen as an act
of political act of breaking the silence
around sexual violence so then it was
considered even more to be breaking for
people to do this and then I suppose
really the history of reclaiming the
night as a social movement and as a
public protest march really lies in
Brussels so over International Women's
Day in March 1976 this tribunal was held
the International Tribunal on crimes
against women over 40 countries
represented over 2000 women attended it
was a test testimony to really about how
patriarchy works in all these different
countries about the form that male
violence against women and children took
in all these different countries you can
imagine it was hardly a heartening event
it must have been quite heartbreaking
actually listening to all those
different testimonies for the whole of
the conference so at the end of that
conference and goodbye all the things
that they'd heard the women decided to
hold a candle lit march through the
centre around where their conference had
been held and that is perhaps the first
sort of documenting nighttime women's
March industries again
violence against women and then the
women who'd been at that conference they
took news of it and off that protest
back to their own countries and to their
own women's groups where they were
organizing themselves and another
reclaim the night march was held in
Berlin it was after the rape and murder
of a young woman there and they
introduced the flaming torches and held
their nighttime marching in 77 and then
in April that year it caught on and
there was synchronised marches so these
are really the world's first
synchronised reclaim the night marches
they happened in several cities across
West Germany they were called Take Back
the Night then and they had slogans such
as women are not cattle to be looked
over women are not pieces of meat they
went out at midnight on the 30th of
April and this was reported in in
Courage magazine which was one of the
women separation magazines of Germany at
the time there was another more popular
one called EMA and which is actually
still running courage was the more sort
of DIY pamphleteer one and it was
reported in there along with photographs
as you can see and then thanks be to
women who could speak and read and write
several different languages we were
working at sparerib at the time when we
like a woman called Amanda Serb stn they
were there in charge of international
mules and it was Virge hog to scan the
women's liberation newsletters and
periodicals from from around Europe and
pick out sort of interesting news items
that might be good for spare rib Sperry
of course one of the you know the most
popular women's liberation periodical in
Britain so there it was it went in in
the August of the summer issue and it
covered it covered those marches in West
Germany and it's got a picture of them
there with their tape back then right
back but they call it reclaim night here
meanwhile in Leeds
a woman called al Garthwaite was
organizing in the Leeds revolutionary
feminist group at that time they'd all
been quite influenced by a paper that
Professor and academic course Sheila
Jeffries had given which was called
against the liberal takeover of our
movement and towards a revolutionary
feminism and she'd given that paper at
this women national women's liberation
conference was held at City Union King
Islington and several groups were very
inspired by that and they took they took
news of that back to their own groups
and in fact there was a specific
conference on revolutionary feminism
which was held in Edinburgh and another
activist Sandra McNiel who went on to be
very influential in British feminism and
particularly in policy work around
violence against children and the
roadman sexual abuse of children she was
at that conference as well and women
started saying has anyone seen the item
in sparerib about the big marches that
were held across Germany why don't we do
similar here and this was particularly
particularly resonated with women in
Leeds and I'm sure some of you will know
why the idea of women taking back the
streets and protesting against male
violence was particularly pertinent to
women organizing in the 1970s in Leeds
and Yorkshire it was of course because
of the acts of one of Britain's most
notorious serial killers Peter Sutcliffe
whom the press dubbed Yorkshire Ripper
now he murdered 13 women over this
period in the 70s and quite a lot of
them were sexual murders as well and so
feminist women were already organizing
around that in Leeds and indeed across
the north of England and so they they
were saying we need to do some similar
to what these women did in Germany we
should go out with flaming torches we
need to reclaim our towns and city
centres women already feel so unsafe
this is a sort of activism that we
should be organizing here and so the
march was advertised in wires which was
the women's information retrieval and
inquiry service which was a sort of
newsletter of the wings iteration
movement which had actually been set up
by our guard waiting the Leeds
revolutionary feminists they'd suggested
it at one of the national conferences I
think in 75 they said there's so much
going on now we need just a uk-wide
newspaper that has all the events and
groups as people are losing track of
everything that's going on that idea was
passed and Leeds published wires for a
number of years I think six or seven
years until it moved on to women in York
so you can see there they advertised it
women in West Germany demonstrated for
the right to walk unafraid and unhe salt
on the streets at night they were torch
lit processions throughout towns all
over West Germany women in Britain are
afraid to walk home at night especially
with all the recent rape reports fresh
in our minds couldn't we organize
similar national demonstration to help
tone our fear into anger and action and
that was the real motivation that you
can see coming out behind all the
reclaiming that marches when they
started